>> Hello and thank you for
joining us this afternoon.
My name is Kathy McGuigan and I work
on the Education Outreach Department
at the Library of Congress.
We are thrilled to welcome you to the second
annual online conference for educators.
I'd like to introduce you to Lee Ann Potter,
the Director of Educational Outreach.
>> Thanks, Kathy.
Good afternoon, everyone.
As Kathy said, I am the Director of
Educational Outreach at the Library of Congress.
And I also am delighted to welcome all of you
to our second annual online
conference for educators.
And specifically, to this
very special keynote session.
It is my pleasure to introduce
award-winning author, Tonya Bolden.
Tonya was born in New York
City and grew up in Harlem.
As a child, she loved to read.
She attended a public elementary school and
a private secondary school in Manhattan.
She graduated from Princeton
with a degree in Slavic Languages
and Literature with a Russian focus.
Bolden is the author of more
than 20 books for young people.
A skilled researcher, she has harnessed
the power of the past in her books.
She combines vivid story telling with links
to primary sources and firsthand accounts
of life during the time period
when a particular book takes place.
She has received a Coretta Scott-King Honor, a
James Madison Award, a Carter G. Woodson Award
and a National Council for Teachers
of English Orbis Pictus Honors.
Today's presentation will focus
on four specific works of hers.
Maritcha, A 19th Century Girl , Searching
for Sarah Rector, The Richest Black Girl
in America , Capital Days, Michael
Shiner's Journal and the Gross Growth
of our Nation's Capital , and her most
recent work, How to Build a Museum,
the Smithsonian National Museum of
African-American History and Culture .
Which chronicles the history behind
the development and the building
of the latest museum on the National Mall.
Elementary school librarian and past Library
of Congress Teacher in Residence, Tom Bober,
will facilitate our conversation this afternoon.
Tom, a librarian at RM Captain Elementary in
Clayton, Missouri has used primary sources
on historical and scientific
topics from the Library of Congress
to help students construct knowledge.
And I might add, Tom has a particular skill
with audiovisual materials
in the Library's collections.
We are thrilled to welcome both Tom and
Tonya and thank you all for being here.
>> Thank you so much, Lee
Ann, for the introduction.
And I just wanted to say that I am really
honored too to be here with you all
and to be having the [inaudible] opportunity to
talk to Tonya and to facilitate today's keynote.
We're going to start off Tonya with talking
about Searching for Sarah Rector ,
a book that I was familiar with before we
had the opportunity to meet up just recently.
And it's one that I think really speaks to a
lot of people because we have a book that is
about someone who is really unknown but is what
we also have revealed is this time in history,
this moment in history through the
information about this young lady.
And so I wondered, Tonya, if you would start off
by telling us just a little bit about the book?
But also telling us about
the inspiration for the book.
Where did you get the idea
to tell us Sarah's story?
>> Hi, Tom.
I stumbled upon the story.
It was, I think, in 2010?
A librarian in Connecticut sent me an email and
there was an attachment and it was an article
from The Crisis about Sarah Rector.
And I thought, never heard of her.
I don't know that much about Oklahoma.
And I just said, "I want to do this story."
And after I got the green light to do it,
then I went into panic mode because, you know,
there are very few secondary sources.
So I had to comb through newspaper
articles and legal documents
which is a long story on how I acquired them.
And it was really, really very scary because,
you know, with that book, with that story,
the story that everyone told was that
during this oil boom in Oklahoma and Texas,
only white men were allowed to be guardians of
oil-rich black children and Indian children.
And that all the white guardians
ripped all the children off.
And as I'm doing the research and using common
sense, I'm saying, "I don't think that's true."
So I did a lot of second
guessing of myself but in the end,
I decided to go with my gut and
go with what I saw was true.
Yes, some children were ripped off but not all.
>> And as I'm reading -- as I read
Sarah Rector for the first time,
one thing that I learned was
the history of enslaved blacks
and that they were held by
Indians from the Southeast.
It wasn't something that
I was previously aware of.
It was this piece of American history
that was new to me and it made me wonder.
Was there a piece of history around Sarah --
or any of your other books that surprised you
or caught you off guard or maybe
even changed how you viewed a moment
or an event or a group in history?
>> Well, Tom, that's a good question.
I'm always learning because you know,
when you see a finished book of mine,
maybe when I started the book, I knew
about 5% or 10% of what's in the book.
So yeah, I didn't know anything
about the so-called Five Civilized
Tribes holding blacks in slavery.
And so, and I didn't -- I had
no idea that there were people
of African descent on the Trail of Tears.
I remember in a book -- my book on
the New Deal, FDR's Alphabet Soup --
I found an article at which there was a
man who had been released from prison.
And a few months after he was released, he was
back at the prison gates, begging to be let back
in because he was broke and hungry.
And I thought, "Wow, this really happened?"
>> Yeah, you get these moments and I think
this really comes forth in your writing too
when you share all of this research out that
there are these small moments in history
that were not things that we learned in
school or not things that you see maybe
when you're watching some kind of broadcast.
That there's these more nuanced things
that are happening in historical moments
that maybe aren't what we expect and really
kind of reshape what we thought to be true.
>> Well, Tom -- that's the wonder.
This is why I love doing history so much.
Because it's an adventure.
It's discovery.
It's a journey.
It's lifelong learning.
And you often find in history
things that are stranger
or more wonderful or wondrous than in fiction.
>> Speaking of fiction, you mentioned in
your author's note of Sarah's story this idea
of separating fact from fiction
when you're doing research.
And I was wondering how you sorted through
conflicting statements about Sarah's story
or any of the people and
events you've researched.
Was there this rule of thumb that you
could follow that you could share with us?
Or was it more of a case-by-case basis?
>> Well, it depends.
I mean, one rule is that generally, the source
that's closest to the subject is more accurate.
So you had newspapers in Chicago
saying this happened to Sarah,
that's happened to Sarah, this is wrong.
And then I started to notice also that a lot
of newspapers just cut and
paste from other newspapers.
So everyone's saying the same thing and I
said, "You know, she lived in Muskogee County."
And I started to find that in
Muskogee County, articles about her.
You had less outrageous things,
claims being made.
So that's one rule of thumb is the source
closest is generally more accurate.
And then it was common sense because I realized,
wait a minute, this is the early 1900s.
They don't have investigative reporters
going from Chicago to Oklahoma.
Few people had telephones.
So I said, "How could they verify any of this?"
>> Yeah, I think the one thing that
really came across in the story too
and I think you're speaking to this is
there is this -- there is this perspective,
there is this -- bias might be too
strong of a word that really comes across
and comes through in newspaper articles.
So for example, you speak or write
a lot about the Chicago Defender.
And they were really defenders
of Sarah and her well-being.
I was wondering what benefits you see in
sources that have this really clear perspective?
They have a slant.
They have a -- something
that they're really pushing
for when you're researching
a story like Sarah's.
Does that make a difference in how you accept
the source or how you deal with the source
or come to understand what it's saying?
>> Yeah and I understand it too because
at the time, there were a lot of children,
black and Indian being ripped
off by white guardians.
But we always know that, you
know, we can't generalize.
Nothing is always and everyone.
So like I said, you take
things with a grain of salt.
You know if a newspaper has a certain agenda.
You know, and this is at a
time when you had, you know,
lynchings and all -- you know, Jim Crow.
So I could understand the bias.
But even in secondary sources, there are
certain scholars that I found to be, you know,
really balanced and not have an agenda.
And others, I always know to
take this with a grain of salt.
They kind of have an agenda.
Like for example, when I'm in the 19th
century, Eric Foner or is it Foner?
He's usually my go-to guide because I found
him to be very thorough and very balanced.
>> And how do you just -- how do you kind of
discovery that thoroughness and that balance,
I guess is something I'm wondering
about when I hear you say that.
Is that bringing in those primary sources along
with these secondary sources
that you're mentioning?
Or what reveals that to you?
>> I think that comes with time.
I think when I first started out, I just --
with anyone that had a PhD so
okay, well they must be right.
And then after a while, you --
it's like a gut thing, you know.
When people will say with Abraham
Lincoln certain things he said,
they'll kind of downplay it.
And I think, no, okay.
I know I really can't trust you.
But it's a gut -- it's a gut thing.
And like you said, after a while, if you've
read a lot of Eric Foner's work, you know --
you feel like you know him
and you can trust him.
>> You said something there that just,
that made me kind of want to circle back
to the primary sources that you dealt with.
You said that you really felt
like at a point that you knew him,
that you knew his work, his
secondary source work.
And it made me wonder then
about something like --
going back to the Chicago
Defender, if you'll let me.
I'm guessing at a point when you
read enough of their work as well,
do you feel like you know their work and
who they are and what their priorities are?
>> Yeah, you do because you could tell, you
know, their interest in sensation, you know.
And they want to sell newspapers.
You know and you just -- you
kind of, yeah, get a feel for it.
And then too, along the way,
I started to [inaudible].
I can't remember any now but discrepancies,
things that I knew were not true --
small things that they were claiming.
And so then you start to you know,
the red flags go up and you say, okay,
let me take this with a grain of salt.
>> Wonderful.
Well, as I'm going through and we're looking
at different images that are either directly
from searching for Sarah Rector or are
related to the time period and the event
that Sarah Rector really has revolved around.
And Tonya, we're going to transition,
if we can into Maritcha now.
This book also focuses on one
individual and one time period.
And was actually, as I mentioned
earlier, and I misspoke.
I apologize but one of the books
that I was really very familiar with,
kind of right off the bat and
have used with my students
and students have really
connected with it as well.
Can you tell us a little bit about this
book and where it came from and where
that inspiration for you came for Maritcha?
>> Once again, I owe it all
to a librarian [laughter].
Diana Lachatanere at the Schomburg Center
for Research in Black Culture in Harlem,
one day said to me -- I was
there researching something.
And she said to me very casually, "You know,
we have this memoir unfinished of this,
you know, black woman, a New Yorker."
She just said very casually, "You
might want to take a look at it."
And so I went to the microfilm, micro
page and I, you know, read it and I said,
"I have to do this story because you know, if
I were around in the 19th century in New York,
you know, I would want to be Maritcha.
I would want to be her friend."
And also because it's -- sometimes,
you know the way black history,
black lives are presented, it's very narrow.
So you either think that everybody was enslaved
and I do descend from people who were enslaved.
And most were in the 19th century.
And if they were free, you'd
imagine that they are bedraggled
and poor and, you know, and downtrodden.
And yeah, there was some of that but
there was always a black middle class.
I remember when the book came out, and one
teacher said, "You know, I never thought about,
you know, there being a black
middle class in the 19th century."
And I said, "Who did you think
Frederick Douglass hung out with?"
>> [Laughter] Absolutely.
You're absolutely right.
And it is -- you did such an
amazing job of revealing that.
I'm sorry, go ahead.
>> I was going to say the
other inspiration is that
and when I work with kids, I tell them this.
I said, "Maritcha represents who most of us are,
ordinary people doing our jobs,
helping in our communities."
You know, for example, she was among the
women who did that fundraiser for Ida B. Well
that allowed her to publish
her anti-lynching pamphlets.
And I think the other thing is that
Maritcha grew up to be a teacher.
And when I was a little girl and
people said, "What do you want to be?"
I used to say, "Teacher."
So there was that connection like -- and
she devoted like 50 years of her life.
And that was at a time, as you
know, when women, if they will --
if they wanted to remain school
teachers, they could not marry.
>> That is right, absolutely.
So yeah, you've got these -- what I'm hearing
you're making these wonderful connections
between -- in some ways, yourself and Maritcha,
and I'm wondering when you read her piece
that inspired this work, you
mentioned I need to tell this story.
Did you know right away that this was
a book or was it more an idea of I need
to know more or I want to know more?
>> It was both.
It was this is a story that needs
to be told and I want to know more.
And the other connection we had is that
as you know, when she went to Providence,
she was the first black girl in the
Girl's Department in the high school
and for the first year, no one spoke to her.
I mean, she really got the cold shoulder.
And I sort of had a similar experience.
I mean, no one gave me the cold
shoulder but you know I went
to a predominantly white secondary
school so there was that connection.
>> I want to jump in and move -- kind of take
those connections and move into one thing
that I noticed as I was connecting
with your book.
And that was the amazing images within
it and really within all of the books
that we're going to be talking about today.
It's just chockfull of these images
and they really, for the reader,
play a role in the storytelling that's going on.
And so it really made me wonder what
role images, photos, maps, drawings,
all of those played in your research and your
understanding of in this case, Maritcha's story.
>> Well, to me, the narrative and
the artwork, they're all of a piece
like I could say tomorrow whatever project I'm
working on, I'm going to get up and I'm going
to write chapter one or chapter
three or whatever.
And then find like it's not happening?
And then sometimes, I'll just start
searching the internet for images
and then I find something
that inspires the narrative.
So they go hand in hand.
I mean, I always want the images to tell some
more of the story, not just be decorative.
And I try to avoid stereotypes.
You know, I think that's very
important for the children's books.
Well, in everyone's books.
For example, there was a case in
my book, IT Cause on Reconstruction
when I covered the transcontinental railroad.
And there's in one way, a wonderful image of
workers, Chinese men and Irishmen working on it.
But their caricature was in stereotypes
and I knew I had to say in the caption,
even the Harper's Weekly considered itself,
you know, liberal and sophisticated.
It wasn't -- they still sometimes
engage in stereotypes.
>> One other thing, Tonya, that this
story did for me was reveal another moment
that I was unaware of and that
was the 1863 New York draft riots.
And you did an amazing job connecting these
riots into Maritcha's life experiences
as I'm sure she did in her
initial writing as well.
It made me wonder what you knew about the
riots before reading Maritcha's autobiography.
And specifically as a researcher, what
about that moment in her life led you
to research it as thoroughly as you did?
>> Well, what led me to research it thoroughly
was because, you know, her home was attacked.
And you know, the kids, the family had to flee.
So it could have been -- I mean,
they could have been killed.
But I think also because I
thought I, as a New Yorker,
never heard of the New York City draft riots.
You know, it just reminded you too about
like, you know, what history has left
out because you know, we have those.
So what I was coming up, history with
flashcard history was very simple, right?
And so during the Civil War, all of the people
in the North were virtuous and righteous.
All of the people in the South were bad.
And you realize when you learn about the
draft riots that that wasn't -- it's not true.
And so, like I said, this happened in my city.
And I never knew about it.
And I believe today, it's still considered the
worst riot in the nation's history, I think.
>> You know what?
I don't know.
It certainly said -- I can imagine
that from the description in your book
and from then some follow-up research that
I did because you're writing intrigued me
and made me want to look further into it.
Is -- are there pieces I would imagine that
are parts of Maritcha's story or really any
of the stories you want to tell, but
you just can't quite work into the book
that you wished that you would share?
Be able to share with people are these
little nuggets of knowledge that you pull
from these primary or secondary sources that are
out there that just don't have an opportunity
to make it out into the final product?
>> You know, Tom, definitely, yes.
Can I think of one now?
No. Maybe [laughter].
>> It's okay.
>> You know, sometimes it may be -- because
sometimes I can be like a dog with a bone, like,
I want everything in and I realize, you
know what, this is too much information.
I remember, once I was working on something
else and I kept insisting and going on, and on,
and on about the My Lai Massacre and my editor
was younger, and she was like, that's enough.
And I realized because I lived through that,
I mean not through the massacre itself,
but that was huge news when I was young.
So sometimes I can go overboard with
things that are -- you know, touch me.
But I'll try to think of an example.
>> So Tonya, I love this -- this video for
several reasons, but I want to just point
out a few that I -- since I have the
opportunity that I really connect to.
This idea that you've got one student here
who's really personalizing this look at history
when she says that Maritcha,
for her is a role model.
She wants to follow her.
She saw something in her beyond that
flashcard history that you mentioned again.
If I can bring that up.
And I think that that was powerful.
And the other thing that I love about this is --
is sometimes the little nuances
that you can find
in book primary sources and secondary sources.
And that you include so wonderfully
in your book, are these little nuances
that the young lady at the end says,
well, this one thing that was interesting
that her parents ran an ice cream shop.
It was again like this very -- this kind
of loose connection, but something that's
so endearing and that, I'm assuming,
really brought that student into the moment
and into the learning that was going on --
around Maritcha and her life and
the events that were surrounding it.
>> Yeah. You know, the thing is, you know, you
write books, you put it out there, you know,
we do school visits and things, but you
never know, like, how many people you touch.
And that's why it was so wonderful to hear
that she sees Maritcha as a role model.
And on the ice cream shop, yeah, it's kind
of intuitive, I guess, when you're writing
for young people, you know, you think they
will enjoy this, you know, it'll mean something
to children because I remember
what it was like to be a child.
For example, if I'm -- talking about something
with money and trying to give a value to it,
I think I did it in Sarah Rector,
I think -- it wasn't an ice cream.
It was maybe a sundae, when I
was trying to say what, you know,
what you could get for a dollar or whatever.
I always try to make it something
that a young person can relate to.
And during the pause, Tom, I did think
of an example of what I left out.
>> Wonderful.
>> In Sarah Rector, I read a few articles,
probably in the Muskogee Times Democrat,
that her father sometimes,
like, got into fights.
You know, got a little tipsy.
And I didn't think I needed to put that in,
but one of the things that that information did
for me was boost my confidence in what
I believe was a truth in this story.
Because when I would tell people, you know,
well it seems like the parents asked this other
person to be the guardian and they would say,
well maybe he was -- a gun was put to
his head or maybe he was threatened.
Now seeing these articles where he was a
kind of a rough and tough guy, I said, nah,
I don't think this is the kind of
man who'd be bullied into anything.
But I didn't feel, as I said,
that I needed to include
that her father got into fights in the book.
>> Wonderful.
So it kind of informed the narrative,
but it didn't necessarily show itself
in the final narrative, which I think is --
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah, which I think is a
wonderful example of these --
again, all of these wonderful nuances when
you bring all of these different types
of sources together, that really informs
the story that you end up wanting to tell.
>> Tom, you know what?
I don't think it's really me.
I feel fortunate.
It's like stories choose me.
And my process is messy, you know.
I feel like I just stumble upon things.
So maybe it's a case of when the
student is ready, the teacher appears.
But it's like, I -- really I stumble
upon so much stuff -- and I think --
>> Oh, go ahead.
I'm sorry.
>> -- because [inaudible].
My philosophy is that, you know, writing is
acting and research is getting into character.
And that research is not just fact
finding and getting dates of things.
It's really immersing yourself in a subject.
It's surrendering to a subject.
And I think when you -- you do
that, good things happen to you.
>> I'm writing this down because I love it and
I might need to share this with my students.
Writing is acting.
Research is getting into character.
And I think you're right, I
mean, this is -- a really --
a wonderful way for us to think
about the stories that we tell,
but the preparation for the
stories that we tell.
That research is so important to being able
to give a full picture and the picture that --
that is really out there as best as we can.
>> The research is everything.
Everything is in the research.
I find, in my -- my experience, the voice, how
you open, like I said, with the F. D. R. book,
that -- I used that example of that man begging
to be allowed back into prison in the opening
and saying, you know, and lots of --
millions of people were broke and hungry.
I don't plan these things.
I just -- like I said, I immerse
myself, I surrender and then it comes.
Titles, maybe not so much titles,
but openers, endings come out of --
I stumble upon things during the research
and I think, oh, this is the way to start.
You know, I -- never really have a map.
I've sort of have a map, but the map usually
is -- is nothing like the final journey.
>> Well, I love that idea that, yeah,
you have this idea of where you're going
and maybe that's not where you end up.
Let's go ahead and explore that a little
more as we move into Capital Days:
Michael Shiner's Journal and the
Growth of Our Nation's Capital.
In it you tell, not only the story of Michael
Shiner, but also the story of Washington,
D.C. from the burning of D.C. during
the war of 1812 to the Civil War
and the end of slavery and much in between.
And in some ways, for me, this book felt
the most familiar because there are events
and places that, I think, most of us are
familiar with, but because of this, I think,
it was also the most revealing in some ways.
Showing me a depth to those
familiar moments that was new to me.
And I want to ask you, if I could,
about something in your author's note.
You can tell I love author's notes.
I think they're very revealing.
You mention in your author's note from
Michael Shiner's story that you're not afraid
as a researcher to say, I don't know.
How does that freedom of being able to say
that impact how you approach your research
and how you share that research in your writing?
>> Again, it comes down to thinking,
for example, one point in Capital Days,
I mention that he lived in X place, you know,
and he was enslaved at the time and I said
that we don't know exactly where because
enslaved people weren't in the directories.
You know, sometimes you can figure
out why you don't know something
and other times you just have to say,
for example, he wrote very little
about his family, his immediate family.
He never mentioned whether
he had siblings or not.
So you -- could just say we don't know, and I
think we all, especially our young people need
to understand that, you know, as I said,
almost every book is a work in progress
and that we don't know everything because we
never know -- we don't know what's been lost.
That's what I think we forget.
Because a -- you know, especially
in D. C., right, with fires
and other cities in the 19th century.
You know, there were fires.
There were, you know, natural disasters.
There were wars.
So we don't know how much we lost.
>> And I think you're actually supposed --
>> I think it's liberating to say we don't know.
I remember once, some young person
said to me about Maritcha when I said,
she may have played this,
she may have played that.
He said, so you don't really know.
And I said, "Bingo, right."
But what I can do is do the research
and see what games were popular
in the 19th century and then say maybe.
Because I think before, a lot of times for
children and for adults, people would --
you know, just kind of maybe make
things up or, you know, skirt around it,
but I think we have to say we don't know.
>> I love that word, also, you
just used, that word maybe.
And I think it's very -- another kind of
probably freeing word to be able to say
that maybe this is what it was like.
And it's based off of that
research that you've done.
I think in -- in Capital Days, I'm going to
guess just maybe because of the location,
maybe where you've done your most research
with Library of Congress resources.
And I know from reading author's
notes that you've done research
with other major institutions as well.
After researching several books -- for
several books, excuse me, how is your approach
to research changed over the years?
How have you honed that ability and
what are some tricks that you know now
that you wish you had known when
researching for an earlier book?
>> Good question.
Well, Tom, I've become bolder.
As I tell young people, you know, you don't --
to write something, you don't need to
know everything, but you need to be able
to find people who know more than you
do and then convince them to help you.
So I guess I'm at a point now
that I could be -- I don't know.
The President has some information,
I would try to get it -- get to him.
So for example, I reached out to John G.
Sharp for Capital Days because, you know,
he had transcribed Shiner's journal
and I found his email and said,
I'm interested in doing a,
you know, book for children.
Could I pick your brain sometime?
And he said, great, I wanted
his story to get out there.
And then I sent him a copy of
Maritcha's -- kind of this kind of book.
Also, with Dr. Adrian Cannon at
Library of Congress, there was --
I had mixed information -- or conflicting
information rather, on who sold the book
and how much it sold for when it
was sold to the Library of Congress.
So, I didn't know her.
So it was like, Hi, I'm Tonya Bolden,
you know, and I want to know this.
Can you please tell me?
And she gave me the information and
then, you know, I always say to people,
if you want to know more about my
work, you can check out my website.
You know, and let them know that -- you
know, I'm not trying to get other people
to do my work for me, but I just need help.
And I find that, especially
librarians, of course, and teachers,
and archivists, they're there to help.
So, you know, too, when people ask me about
process, I often say read my acknowledgements.
So I wish when I was younger, I wish I had
been bolder about reaching out to experts.
I once emailed Eric Foner about something.
I was looking for an image of a black
Representative, I think, from South Carolina
and I just wanted to know, you know,
have you ever seen an image of this man?
And I don't know if it was him,
but somebody for him, you know,
responded to me saying that,
no, we've never seen it.
>> This is a whole new type of
sleuthing, like digging up email addresses
and contact information for
individuals to make these connections.
To really reach out there and go beyond
what maybe is right in front of you.
How do you make that decision?
How do you make the decision to say, I think
this may be here, or is it more of a --
an intuition of saying, I
want this and so I'm going
to contact someone who may know more about it?
>> Yeah, it's like -- like, I want
to know this, I want to know this.
I went overboard in Sarah Rector because,
even though I knew I had the information
on when she sold her allotment,
the land on which she had oil,
but I wanted to know what happened to that land.
So I tracked someone down at the Oklahoma
something or something Oil something
and they referred me to someone else, and
this wonderful woman ended up tracking --
she had like 30, I think, oil wells,
and -- giving me the documentation,
showing that years later some
were -- when they were capped.
When each oil well was capped and then
years later, that with new technology,
some of the wells were being drilled again.
And at the time of publication of
the book, there were still some
of her wells that were in operation.
That wasn't really vital to
the story, but I was just like,
I want to know what happened to her oil wells.
Oh, -- yeah, with John G. Sharp, there was --
there's a scene in Capital Days when Shiner
has a pass to go someplace for the holidays
and on his way back -- Christmas holiday, on his
way back some people in Fort Washington stop him
and think he's a runaway enslaved
person, and they want to, you know.
And I'm thinking, why doesn't he
just show them his pass, right?
Because every time I've heard
about people having passes --
blacks having passes, they
had to have them on them.
So I -- I emailed John and said,
why didn't he just show the pass?
He said, no, for the Navy Yard, you gave
your pass to the sentry when you left.
I said, oh, okay.
>> And some of these primary
sources I'm seeing, as I'm talking,
you're talking about the Navy Yard,
which we had an image of earlier.
You were talking about the oil
wells which we had some imagery,
maybe not of Sarah Rector's oil wells, but
just that area and the oil wells on them
and what that looked like earlier.
Really providing a rich visual to accompany
these pieces of knowledge that -- that really --
that you reach out for and get from
these experts out in the field.
Those people who, as you mentioned,
know more than you and you need
to convince them to help you out.
Tonya, I wanted -- oh please.
Go ahead.
>> I always send them a copy of the book.
>> have you had people reach out to
you, Tonya, in the same vein and say,
well maybe even a younger student and say, I
want to know more about Sarah, or Maritcha,
or Michael and -- and maybe they've got a
specific question that isn't in your book?
>> I've had a few adult people, I think
some -- one of them wanted to find --
she thought that there was
a connection with someone
in her family and Maritcha and she inquired.
I don't get that many from young people.
Sometimes, to be honest,
I will get an email and --
and they really want me to
do their work for them.
You know, it's like, can you tell
me who George Washington Carver is?
[Laughter] One thing, can you back up
to the -- are we able to back up photos?
>> Yeah. Wherever you would like to go.
>> Lincoln's Inauguration.
Some might say, oh but it's blurry, right.
But that's why I love it, because in the
caption, because I know Shiner was there,
and I can say, in this crowd
might be Michael Shiner.
And the imagination can look at, you
know, do I see a black man in the --
we don't know if he was light-skinned.
We don't know if he was dark-skinned,
but with the blurriness
and all of that, -- so I don't know.
I can even make use of mistakes.
>> I think that -- yeah,
absolutely, just as you mentioned,
let the imagination, the maybes come out there.
And Tonya, I don't want to -- don't
want to cut the conversation off,
but I do want to spend just a
moment talking about, if we could,
How to Build a Museum, your newest book.
I really enjoyed it.
I just -- I received an advance copy to
look through, so I could get a little bit
of a preview, but I have my -- my brand new copy
that just kind of came hot off the press here.
And just one quick question and that is,
you know, it seems like that a large part
of your research for this book, unlike your
others, was researching a more recent event.
An event kind of as it was happening.
You're writing about the museum being put
together as it was actually happening.
So, if you could tell us briefly, how was that
different, or similar to researching for some
of your other books that maybe
took place a century or more ago?
>> Well, it was similar in a way to Shiner,
Maritcha, and Sarah Rector because all I had
to do -- most -- what I had to deal with, when
I got to the actual part of the book that deals
with the building of the museum
was first drafts of history.
So newspaper articles, interviews,
and in newspaper articles sometimes,
or magazine articles, sometimes have mistakes.
And in interviews, sometimes people misspeak.
So, you know, I would have to confirm --
get a lot of things confirmed because
I'm like, is this really true?
Do they really own this item?
Do they have this in the collection?
So that was -- that was exhilarating.
Also, things were constantly changing.
So at one point, because this is what I
was -- the information documents I got.
The base of the museum was going to be like
a platform or plant, and then it changed.
So it was just -- it was just staying alert
and then, too, I also knew that in the end
of the day, the deputy director, the director,
and other members of the staff were going
to read it and they would, you know,
update me if I needed updating.
So, but it was -- it was exciting.
Sometimes I would do things like,
say if this was this time last year,
I would just search engine NMAAHC and the
day's date to see if anything new had come
because it got so much coverage, so much
press, that things were always changing.
Things were always being acquired.
So it was, like I said, it was a thrilling ride.
>> Absolutely.
And I -- I think, actually, that -- that answer
that you shared with us really kind of leads
into one of our audience questions
that I'd love to pose to you.
Is there an average amount of time that you
spend researching before you begin writing?
How do you know, I guess, when it is
time to write and how does that idea
of researching and writing work together?
>> Oh, it's all like a messy jumble.
It was like I'd research to a
point and then I'll find something
and I'll say, okay, this is my way in.
and then I'd know where I'm starting.
But it could be -- what -- after that will be
a big TK because I don't know what I'm doing.
But I -- have to have a way in.
And then once I'm in, then
I fumble and stumble around.
It's really -- yeah, I'm not a person who says,
I want to do all the research
then I'm going to write.
Sometimes I may write something that's not based
on research, but it's like a concepty thing.
Like I said, my process is really, really messy.
I just sort of, you know,
follow the spirit in a way.
>> And with that, is there a -- I know you
say it's messy and I guess -- I think --
I wonder if some of our audience members are
kind of a little more curious about what some
of the messiness looks like, in
addition to what you shared already.
This idea of -- is there a
process that you go through?
And someone asked this question; do you have a
preferred method of processing through a book,
or does each book proceed in its own manner?
And I'm going to guess from the
messiness, there's some uniqueness to it.
I guess I'm -- I'm kind of more interested
in some of the similarities maybe.
>> Yeah, when I've gone into
starting a book thinking, okay,
I know how this is going
to work, it doesn't work.
Because Michael Shiner is based -- Capital Days
is based on a journal and Maritcha's is based
on a memoir, I thought they
going to have the same structure.
But it didn't work because they're totally
different people, you know, she was Victorian
and prim and proper, and he was
rough and tumble, and it didn't work.
And I needed to start -- he was a man of action.
I needed to start that book with action.
So I started with the War of 1812.
What I mean by messiness, is -- is I -- I flit.
You know, like I said, I may start writing
and then say, okay, this is not happening.
You can feel it when you're not in the zone.
And I'll say, so go do picture research,
or I know when I can't write on say --
I don't know, a bill or a war
or something like that, I know.
You know why?
Because you don't really understand
it, you need to go do more research.
Because when I start a book,
I'm usually in a panic.
>> When you start researching
or you start writing?
>> When I have to start working on it.
Like once it gets to -- before it gets
to greenlight I'm like, I can do this.
Yes, I can do this.
And then after it gets to greenlight,
I'm like a mass of insecurity
and it's like I can't do this.
I won't be able to do this.
>> And I guess there's something
else I'm hearing too,
and I'm wondering if you can speak towards this,
and I'm thinking about myself as a researcher,
as kind of a casual researcher, my students
as researchers, this idea of flitting.
The word maybe that came to my
mind maybe also is backtracking,
when you're saying I don't
know enough about this.
>> Yeah.
>> How does that work for you?
And -- it almost feels like that could be like a
really freeing kind of thing while also, maybe,
a little panicky sort of feeling as well.
>> Yeah, well, when I was younger, I would
just write things and know that it had no heart
and soul and it was cold and then just
hope an editor didn't notice or something.
But now, I'll stop and say, wait a minute,
the reason you can't write this is
because you don't understand it.
You know, and it made me more
work, but go do more work.
>> Absolutely.
And Tonya, yeah, and I think, I think this is
a wonderful point to kind of wrap, but I --
first of all wanted to thank you, not only for
sharing some of the insights into that messiness
that you described, but also giving us
the opportunity to think about ourselves
as researchers and our students
as researchers through you.
I think much as the way as you are making
connections to Maritcha and I'm sure
in many ways, to all of the people that
you've researched, I'm making connections
with you right now, and the
things you're telling me.
Giving me some things to think about.
And -- expanding kind of my
base of what I am able to do.
Maybe encouraging me, as you
mentioned, to be a little more bold.
A little more daring with who I reach out to.
And so, I want to take this opportunity
to thank you for starting us off
with our Library of Congress Online Conference.
>> Thank you.
Thank you, Tom.
Thank you everyone at Library of Congress.